you know what i want to do i want to
make a youtube video about the truth of
gumball rally oh man
[ __ ] show wait wait yeah but it was this
this thing that they do every year with
like a bunch of just obnoxiously wealthy
people and all these luxury cars and
they just pick some
journey to go on for us it was we raced
cars with millionaires from london to
russia and back in a huge circle through
12 countries some billionaires yeah
max cooper puts it together but i
remember like you think it's a bunch of
millionaires and billionaires and
but they had pretty good spirit they're
pretty good spirits oh for sure yeah
it's the fun ones yeah totally i mean if
you're doing something like that these
guys want to
like
pedal to the metal so that that was a
jackass special and like how did that
even come up like uh i was
i'd gone to london
with um
mike ballard okay right
to film
the me getting shot out of a cannon in
brixton and my friend john morales drove
us to brixton but he john had a friend
max cooper max cooper comes over and
said hey
i'm just getting this i've done this a
couple times this gumball rally thing do
you guys want to do it and so i took it
to jeff and spike and they thought it
would be fun and did mtv go for it right
away
oh i don't remember i think at that time
mtv was pretty happy like
to do what i mean the show was doing
good so right so so we start out and
it's it's knoxville
and and
me and pontius in the car
with like one one other person ponies
and i are in the back seat with gooch
was driving and someone else maybe
dimitri was in the front seat
they had this big ceremony in the middle
of uh like hyde park in in london
they're blowing up fireworks all these
and start and all these luxury cars
taking off
as soon as they start this this race
pontius and i just started jacking up
and i was between them
you know i'm in the back but point
between them this seat is bad enough why
i think you were in the front i think it
was just not in the back oh really i
think so i think so and and i don't even
know why but but uh we decided that we
were going to have a a contest to see
who could blow the most loads in the car
while it was moving and full of dudes
and uh
and
and we've rubbed ourselves raw
like just leaving london there were like
double-decker buses like looking down on
us like you know as they passed
and uh it wasn't until the dead of night
when when i got my uh when i got it done
and i remember which is really weird for
you because uh
right did it take that long it means
your first load you blew
yeah yeah
and and by the time i blasted that one
there was just something about being in
the car full of dudes and of course you
know like yeah you know it was only when
everybody was only once everybody was
asleep except for the driver was i able
to to get it done and i blasted this
window so that i wake up knoxville i'm
like hey knox so wake up dude film this
and and i could make knoxville film i'm
like pan from me and ask me what's that
on the window and i had shot it all over
the window
and uh then like the next morning
knoxville switched cars yeah
by the time we got to france i was out
of there
had fun
2018 b team kind of a thing yeah i was
who won
we were tied four loads of peace
at the end wow it was i mean their
windows looked like a krispy kreme donut
it was just
the smell
oh god that bleachy [ __ ] smell
sure and when it's hot it just i i was i
was outraged because we made sure we
documented every single load and mtv
didn't even show one yeah
my goodness the indignities this man has
had to face
yeah dude